David, so, what problem was this supposed to solve?
大卫，所以，这原本是为了解决什么问题？
The teachers were trying to get the kids to stop tattling.
老师们试图让孩子们停止打小报告。
And why was that so important?
为什么那件事那么重要？
Because it's a pre-K classroom, and it's constant there.
因为那是学前班的教室，在那儿这种情况层出不穷。
Right. I should say, by the way, that you are David Kestenbaum. You are one of our producers, our managing editor right now. And this classroom is your kid's classroom, right?
对。顺便说一下，我得介绍一下，你是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。你是我们的制片人之一，也是我们现在的总编辑。而这个教室是你孩子的教室，对吧？
Yeah. Both of them went there.
是的。他们两个都在那儿上过。
I still don't get-- it seems like kids tattling on each other is just a fact of pre-K.
我还是不明白——孩子们互相打小报告似乎是学前班的常态。
It is, but you've got 20-something kids. I mean, you know, it's hard being one parent with two kids doing it. Imagine you're in a classroom with, like, 20 kids. And if they bring it to you as a teacher, all these little injustices, you've got to get involved in all these cases, you know?
确实是，但你有二十多个孩子。我的意思是，你知道，身为一个有两个孩子的家长处理这些事都很累。想象一下你在一个有20个孩子的教室里。如果他们作为老师把所有这些小小的纠纷都带给你，你得介入所有这些案件，你懂的？
Right. And it's just a time suck.
对。这纯粹是在浪费时间。
Yeah, it's just a time suck. And so one of the teachers had this great idea. She took a tissue box, hung it on the wall, and then took this plastic phone receiver and hung it in it and said something like, that's the tattle-phone. Tell it to the phone. And I thought it was just brilliant.
是的，就是在浪费时间。所以其中一位老师想到了一个绝妙的主意。她拿了一个纸巾盒，挂在墙上，然后在里面挂了一个塑料电话听筒，并说类似“那是告密电话（tattle-phone）。对着电话说吧”。我觉得这简直太天才了。
And I just want to say, this is a place that loves kids. I would go to pick up my son Max, and I would have to wait because he would want to hug every single teacher. And I would go to get Auggie, our older kid, and he would be like, I need five minutes, I'm in the middle of something. Like--
我只想说，这是一个充满爱心的地方。我去接我儿子马克斯时，还得等一会儿，因为他想拥抱每一位老师。我去接我们的大儿子奥吉时，他会说，我需要五分钟，我正忙着呢。就像——
They just want to stay longer.
他们只是想多待一会儿。
I mean, I get choked up thinking about this place. And I love the idea of the tattle-phone, just as a vessel for all the little injustices that go on every day. And I wanted to hear what was said into it-- like, these little three year olds, four year olds talking into this plastic phone.
我的意思是，想到这个地方我就哽咽。我很喜欢这个告密电话的创意，它就像每天发生的所有小纠纷的容器。我想听听人们对着它说了什么——比如这些三四岁的小家伙对着这个塑料电话说了些什么。
OK. And I should say, this is the part of the story I know very well what happens next.
好的。我得说，这是故事中我知道接下来会发生什么的那一部分。
We asked if we could put a phone in the classroom that would record the tattles. The daycare was fine with that. I reached out to the parents. I didn't know how they were going to feel about us recording their kids at, like, the worst moment of the day. But every single one of them said yes. Some of them said please, yes, do this. So we got a phone.
我们询问是否可以在教室里放一部电话来录下这些告密信息。日托中心对此没有意见。我联系了家长们。我不知道他们对于我们在他们孩子一天中最糟糕的时刻录音会有什么感觉。但他们每个人都答应了。有些人甚至说，拜托，是的，一定要这么做。所以我们拿到了电话。
It was this chunky red phone, kind of like 1980s style, we had it set up to record. And we needed an outgoing message for it.
那是一部粗笨的红色电话，有点像80年代风格的，我们把它设置成录音模式。我们需要一条外呼提示音。
And that is where I stepped in.
而那就是我介入的地方。
Hey there, you've reached the tattle phone. OK, tell me what happened after the beep. Tell me the whole story.
嘿，你打通了告密电话。好的，请在哔声后告诉我发生了什么。把整个故事告诉我。
I really hope to make some inroads in that four-year-old market. I really hope that helps our ratings. So what we're going to do now, David, is that you're going to explain what you heard on those recordings on the tattle-phone. And when you're done, I'm going to come back, and I'll explain what today's show is about.
我真的希望能在这个四岁儿童市场打开局面。我真的希望这能提高我们的收视率。那么大卫，我们现在要做的是，你来解释一下你在告密电话的录音里听到了什么。等你讲完，我会回来解释今天节目讲述的内容。
OK. So I brought the phone into class, and I set it up. And the kids started to use it immediately and with great enthusiasm.
好的。我把电话带进了教室，并把它架好了。孩子们立刻就开始使用它，而且非常热心。
Eli told me a lie.
伊莱对我说了谎。
Seamus wasn't sharing with me, and I don't like it, and I'm very upset.
谢默斯不跟我分享，我不喜欢这样，我很难过。
Nathan farted in my face, and I said, yuck, Nathan.
内森冲着我的脸放屁，我说，真恶心，内森。
Catch that one? Nathan farted in my face, and I said, yuck, Nathan. But the real crime?
听见那个了吗？内森冲着我的脸放屁，我说，真恶心，内森。但真正的罪行是？
And he didn't say excuse me.
而且他没说“对不起”。
I think there was enormous excitement just having a phone in the class. It was larger than they'd probably ever seen in their lives-- bright red with buttons on it. It was an old touch-tone phone. Everyone wanted to use it, even if they didn't have a tattle. Kids sang a song into it. One tried to order a pizza. Someone said, hi mom, please pick me up early.
我想教室里有一部电话本身就让他们感到无比兴奋。它比他们一生中见过的任何东西都大——鲜红色，上面有按钮。那是一部老式按键电话。每个人都想用它，即使他们没有小报告要打。孩子们对着它唱歌。有一个孩子试图订披萨。有人说，嘿妈妈，请早点来接我。
Hi, Dad. I love you. Bye.
嘿，爸爸。我爱你。再见。
Uh, our baby turned into a ducky, and I don't know how it turn into a ducky. And that's why her turned into a ducky and turned back to a baby.
呃，我们的宝宝变成了一只小鸭子，我不知道它是怎么变成小鸭子的。这就是为什么它变成了一只小鸭子，然后又变回了宝宝。
Uh-- I'm sorry, I need to hang up on you for one second.
呃——抱歉，我得挂断你一秒钟。
Several calls later, conscience heavy, that kid calls back.
几个电话之后，由于良心不安，那个孩子又打了回来。
I'm sorry I had to hang up on you. I'm just sorry.
很抱歉我不得不挂断你。我真的很抱歉。
The tattle-phone was like a magic portal into one preschool classroom in America, which is kind of incredible. Like most parents I'll ask my kids, what happened in school today, and I get nothing. School is like this black box-- you drop them off, pick them up, and you have no idea what happens in between.
告密电话就像通往美国某学前班教室的魔法门户，这真是不可思议。像大多数家长一样，我会问我的孩子，今天学校发生了什么，但我什么都问不到。学校就像一个黑匣子——你送他们去，接他们回来，完全不知道中间发生了什么。
But now I had this phone. It was set up so it sent me the messages as they happened. It was funny listening to them from my desk. The portal into this classroom would open for a second, I get this little report from a kid, hear a little sound of the room, and then it would close-- sometimes for a while. Then the portal would open, I'd hear something, and then silence again. There were never any tattles between 1 and 3 o'clock, because that was nap time. Then they'd start again, these little dramas.
但现在我有了这个电话。它的设置是让它在消息发生时立即发送给我。在我的办公桌前听这些录音很有趣。通往这个教室的门户会打开一秒钟，我收到某个孩子的小报告，听见一点房间里的声音，然后它就关闭了——有时会关闭很久。然后门户又打开，我听到一些声音，接着又是寂静。下午1点到3点之间从来没有任何告密信息，因为那是午睡时间。然后它们又开始了，这些小小的戏剧。
Ramon is not listening to my teacher, Mr. Evans, but he's my favorite teacher. And I know-- and I know he's mad at me, but I don't want him to be. So I'm trying my best to listen.
拉蒙不听我的老师，埃文斯先生的话，但他是我最喜欢的老师。我知道——我知道他在生我的气，但我不想让他生气。所以我正在尽我所能地去听。
My friend Simone said "no" at me.
我的朋友西蒙娜对我说“不”。
"My friend Simone." It's always their friends who are bugging them.
“我的朋友西蒙娜。”总是他们的朋友在困扰他们。
My friend Jack was in my face when I was waiting to go to an area. And that made me really upset.
当我在等候区的时候，我的朋友杰克冲到了我的面前。这让我非常难过。
(SINGING) Eli hit me. Eli hit me.
（唱歌）伊莱打我。伊莱打我。
Um, when I'm playing family with Simone, [INAUDIBLE] keeping me awake while I'm trying to sleep, pretend sleep.
嗯，当我和西蒙娜玩过家家时，[听不清]在我试图睡觉、假装睡觉的时候让我保持清醒。
Can I just say, I'm not sure that one is actionable. You're pretending to sleep and complaining that someone is waking you up? I don't know.
我能说一句吗，我不确定那个是可以追究的。你假装睡觉，却抱怨别人把你吵醒？我不知道。
People are not sharing the tattle-phone.
大家都没有分享这个告密电话。
How much of their day is about, like, justice?
他们的一天中有多少比例是关于——比如，正义的？
Oh! I couldn't put a percentage on it. But I could say the majority of the day. [LAUGHS]
噢！我无法给它定个百分比。但我可以说占了一天中的大部分时间。[笑]
This is Kathleen Jones, the lead teacher in the class.
这位是凯瑟琳·琼斯，班里的首席老师。
It is everything-- and rules. They live by rules. They can sit down to play a game, and that whole playtime will be nothing but arguing about the rules. And then there's no playtime left, and they feel good about it.
那是一切——还有规则。他们靠规则生活。他们可以坐下来玩游戏，而整个游戏时间都将只是在争论规则。然后游戏时间就没了，他们对结果还感到很满意。
It's funny. Like, they can't make breakfast for themselves, they can't get dressed, they can barely talk, and they're just full of "that's not fair."
这很有趣。就像，他们自己没法做早餐，没法穿衣服，说话都磕磕绊绊，却满口都是“这不公平”。
But they're dynamos. Every one of them has something that--
但他们是发电机。他们每个人都有某种——
It's awesome.
太棒了。
Yes, exactly. It's awesome. They're wonderful.
是的，没错。太棒了。他们真是太好了。
There's actual scientific research on this. Kids know when something's unfair, some when they're just 12 months old. My kids weren't even walking then. And I know this is kind of obvious, but so many of the conflicts in this world come down to some version of what's going on in this classroom-- what's fair, how do you divide up something that there's a limited quantity of.
这方面有实际的科学研究。孩子在12个月大的时候就知道什么是公平的。那时我的孩子甚至还不会走路。我知道这有点显而易见，但世界上太多的冲突归结为我们这个教室里所发生事情的某种版本——什么是公平的，你如何分配数量有限的东西。
You know magnet tiles? We only have one acrylic one that's yellowish gold. That is it. That is the prize in the class. Whoever gets that is like, I'm the king or the queen and ha-ha. The gold-- that's what they call it, the gold.
你知道磁力片吗？我们只有一个黄橙色的亚克力片。就这一个。那是班里的奖品。得到它的人就会像说，我是国王或女王，哈哈。那金色的——他们称之为“黄金”。
I sometimes think that the main usefulness of numbers for my son Max, the whole reason he knows how to count, is score-keeping-- how many of something he has and how many his brother has. It's a weighing of the scales of justice, no matter how tiny.
我有时认为，数字对我儿子马克斯的主要用处，他学习数数的全部原因，就是记分——他有多少东西，他哥哥有多少东西。这是衡量正义天平的一种方式，无论它是多么微小。
So did it work for you? Like, did they stop coming to you with their complaints?
那么它对你有用吗？比如，他们停止来找你投诉了吗？
Yes, it did. It does work. Yes, that phone holds a lot of power.
是的，有效。它确实有效。是的，那部电话掌握着巨大的权力。
It gave the teachers the break they were looking for. I wanted to see if the kids thought it worked, whether the tattle-phone helped them deal with stuff. So the other weekend I interviewed a bunch of them-- which, I have to say, these were some of the weirder interviews I've done in my professional life. Bob Woodward, I know this isn't right, but I had to pay one interviewee a piece of gum. Another kid, Nicky, insisted on performing magic tricks before granting an interview. I did not have high expectations.
它给了老师们他们想要的休息时间。我想看看孩子们是否觉得它管用，告密电话是否帮他们处理了问题。所以上周末我采访了他们中的一群人——我必须说，这些是我职业生涯中做过的最奇怪的采访之一。鲍勃·伍德沃德，我知道这样做不对，但我不得不付给一位受访者一块口香糖。另一个孩子尼基坚持要在接受采访前表演魔术。我并没有抱太高期望。
And then if I do this--
然后如果我这样做——
Wait, that worked really well. Wait, that was actually amazing.
等等，那招很管用。等等，那真的太神奇了。
I know.
我知道。
That was good.
那很棒。
Yeah.
是的。
Nicky then refused to talk about the phone at all. But others clearly used it a lot.
尼基随后拒绝再谈论关于电话的事。但其他人显然用了很多次。
You have to tell the tattle-phone the whole story, what happened.
你必须告诉告密电话整个故事，发生了什么。
That's Gabriel. This is Deenia.
那是加布里埃尔。这是迪尼娅。
Tell me the whole story. That's all I can remember.
把整个故事告诉我。我只能记住这些。
One girl's parents told me that they were on vacation staying at a hotel, which of course had a landline phone. And their daughter, Simone, said, look, a tattle-phone, as if there was some sort of national tattle-phone network, staffed around the clock by government workers entering everything into a database. My friend's kid Sean, who just turned 5 and who I adore, was the only one who could remember a tattle-worthy event from school in any detail. He whispered it to me. He was clearly kind of excited about this. His friend had kicked him.
一个女孩的父母告诉我，他们度假时住在一间酒店，酒店里当然有座机电话。他们的女儿西蒙娜说，看，是一个告密电话，就好像存在某种全国性的告密电话网络，全天候由政府工作人员轮班，将一切录入数据库。我朋友的孩子肖恩，刚满5岁，我非常喜爱他，他是唯一一个能详细记得学校里发生的一件值得告密事件的孩子。他悄悄地告诉了我。他显然对这件事感到有点兴奋。他的朋友踢了他。
(WHISPERING) He kicked me in the penis.
（耳语）他踢了我的阴茎。
(WHISPERING) He what?
（耳语）他什么？
(WHISPERING) Kicked me in the penis.
（耳语）踢了我的阴茎。
(WHISPERING) He kicked you in the penis? Did you tell the tattle-phone?
（耳语）他踢了你的阴茎？你告诉告密电话了吗？
(WHISPERING) That time, we didn't have any tattle-phone.
（耳语）那个时候，我们没有告密电话。
(WHISPERING) Oh, you didn't have the tattle-phone?
（耳语）哦，你们没有告密电话？
(WHISPERING) No.
（耳语）没有。
(WHISPERING) If you had the tattle-phone, would you have told it? Yeah? OK.
（耳语）如果你有告密电话，你会告诉它吗？是吗？好吧。
It sounds like it might have been an accident. Sean stood up and acted out the whole thing in slow motion for me.
听起来那可能是一次意外。肖恩站起来，慢动作地为我重演了整个过程。
Slow motion.
慢动作。
Like it was a scene from an action movie. His friend was trying to kick the ceiling.
就像动作片里的一个场景。他的朋友是在试图踢天花板。
So he went like, [ACTION NOISES].
所以他就像，[动作声]。
They should have a security camera in the classroom.
他们应该在教室里装个监控摄像头。
But they don't.
但他们没有。
They don't? Just the tattle-phone?
他们没有？只有告密电话？
Mm-hmm.
嗯嗯。
A bunch of kids told me they felt good after talking to the tattle-phone, though the why it made them feel better, it took all my interviewing skills. This is Gabriel.
一群孩子告诉我，跟告密电话说了之后他们感觉很好，尽管为什么这让他们感觉更好，耗尽了我所有的采访技巧。这是加布里埃尔。
How did you like having the tattle-phone in the classroom?
你觉得在教室里放告密电话怎么样？
Good.
好。
How did it feel after you said something to the tattle-phone?
你对告密电话说了什么之后感觉怎么样？
Good.
好。
How come you felt good?
为什么你感觉很好？
Uh, because-- well, I felt good because I told on the person.
呃，因为——嗯，我感觉好是因为我告发了那个人。
One girl told me talking to the tattle-phone felt like eating ice cream.
一个女孩告诉我，对着告密电话说话感觉就像吃冰淇淋。
It's nice to think that just getting something off your chest can solve a problem, that if you just release the fact of the injustice into the world you feel better. And sure, I think that can be true. But we had the phone in class for a month, and I did notice toward the end, we got fewer messages. They came in regularly, but not with the same energy.
想到仅仅是倾诉就能解决问题，想到如果你把不公正的事实释放到世界上，你就会感觉好些，这很美好。当然，我认为那可能是真的。但我们在课堂上放了电话一个月，我确实注意到临近尾声时，我们收到的消息变少了。它们还是会定期出现，但没有了同样的能量。
It's possible the novelty was wearing off. I think there's something else going on as well. Before we put the phone in the class, I had it set up in my house, just to make sure it was working. My kids used it a couple of times. And then our younger son Max was complaining that his brother, Auggie, who's a year older, had pinched him.
这可能是新鲜感在消退。我想还有别的事情在发生。在我们把电话放进教室之前，我把它放在家里，以确保它能正常工作。我的孩子们用了几次。然后我们的小儿子马克斯抱怨他哥哥奥吉，比他大一岁，掐了他。
Tell it to the tattle-phone, I said. It's not working, he told me. I picked the phone up worried that there was some technical glitch. But it was fine. It's working, Max. No, he said, it's not.
对着告密电话说吧，我说。它没用，他告诉我。我拿起电话，担心有什么技术故障。但它没问题。它在工作，马克斯。不，他说，没有。
It did not do anything. It doesn't even work to me. It doesn't even do anything.
它什么也没做。它甚至对我都没用。它什么都没做。
It listened to your tattle.
它听到了你的告密。
No, it doesn't.
不，它没有。
What do you mean? It listened.
你什么意思？它听到了。
It didn't. It didn't stop Auggie pinching me.
它没有。它没能阻止奥吉掐我。
It didn't stop Auggie pinching me. I know, Max. I know. Sometimes you want more than just to speak. You want actual justice.
它没能阻止奥吉掐我。我知道，马克斯。我知道。有时你想要的不仅仅是诉说。你想要的是真正的正义。
Thank you, David.
谢谢你，大卫。
You're welcome.
不客气。
And that brings us to-- like, what are we, 12 minutes into the program-- it brings us to what we are doing today on our show. Today we have people, some of them young, some of them old, wanting justice, feeling a sense of injustice, on things as big as the constitutional foundation of our entire country and things as small as the question of whether a ball is in or out. And in all those cases, people young and old not trusting the system to deliver justice. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. Stay with us.
这把我们带到了——我们在节目中过了多久了，12分钟？——它把我们带到了我们今天在节目中要做的事情。今天我们有一些人，有些年轻，有些年长，他们渴望正义，感受到一种不公正，事情大到我们整个国家的宪法基础，小到关于球是在界内还是界外的问题。而在所有这些案例中，无论是年轻人还是老年人都不信任体系能伸张正义。来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这是《美国生活》。请继续收听。
Act One, Hoop Reams. The journalist Michael Lewis, who wrote Moneyball and The Big Short and lots of other books and who contributes to our program now and then, he was looking around at what's going on in America these days. And he noticed that one way you can describe the current moment that we're all living through is that Americans don't trust the refs-- in all walks of life. They don't trust their impartiality.
第一幕，篮球梦想。记者迈克尔·刘易斯，他写了《点球成金》、《大空头》以及许多其他书籍，并不时为我们的节目供稿。他一直在观察美国当下的局势。他注意到，你描述我们所有人正在经历的当下的方式之一，就是美国人不信任裁判——在各行各业都是如此。他们不信任裁判的公正性。
I'm talking about police, Supreme Court justices, journalists, the people who regulate the banks and Wall Street and student loans, the people setting medical costs, judges. So many people today feel the system is rigged. I mean, Bernie Sanders and Donald Trump both ran on that. So many people feel that the figures of authority, charged with enforcing rules impartially, keeping everybody on a level playing field, that they're failing at their jobs. It's not fair.
我说的是警察、最高法院大法官、记者，监管银行、华尔街和学生贷款的人，设定医疗成本的人，法官。今天有太多人觉得这个体系是被操纵的。我的意思是，伯尼·桑德斯和唐纳德·特朗普竞选时都主张这一点。有太多人觉得那些肩负着公正执法、让每个人处于平等竞争环境的权威人物，他们的工作失败了。这不公平。
Michael Lewis has not published this reporting that he's been doing on this in a new book. He's decided to make it into a podcast. They launched this week. It's called Against The Rules. And Michael has adapted a version of their very first episode for us to play for you right now. The first episode is about people not trusting the refs in the most literal sense of that. It's about basketball referees. Here's Michael Lewis.
迈克尔·刘易斯并没有将他一直在进行的这篇报道发表成新书。他决定把它做成一档播客。他们本周上线了。节目叫《规则之外》。迈克尔为我们改编了他们第一集的内容，现在播放给大家听。第一集是关于人们在最字面的意义上不信任裁判的故事。是关于篮球裁判的。这是迈克尔·刘易斯。
For me, this story really begins with my 11-year-old son, Walker. He plays on a basketball team run by a Japanese Buddhist temple. My son isn't a Buddhist, though most of the time he could pass for one. He has no conflict with his teachers or his classmates or his Japanese Buddhist teammates.
对我来说，这个故事确实始于我11岁的儿子沃克。他效力于一支由日本佛寺运营的篮球队。我儿子不是佛教徒，尽管大多数时候他看起来很像。他和老师、同学或日本佛教徒队友之间没有什么冲突。
I wouldn't say his mind is exactly pure, but usually it's calm. The exception is when he deals with refs. Even in what amounts to a Buddhist basketball game, anytime a ref blows the whistle on him, he throws up his arms in astonishment. Then he jumps up and down with his little fists balled up and his mouth clenched tight, so everyone knows just how much injustice he's suffering. Then he marches off with a scowl. And he doesn't get over it. After a game this season, he gets into the car and starts bitching and moaning all over again.
我不会说他的头脑绝对纯洁，但通常都很冷静。例外是在他面对裁判的时候。即使是在某种相当于佛教徒的篮球比赛中，只要裁判对他吹哨，他就会惊愕地举起双臂。然后他会挥舞着小拳头，紧咬牙关蹦蹦跳跳，好让每个人都知道他受了多大的不公正待遇。然后他会气冲冲地走开。而且他对此耿耿于怀。这个赛季的一场比赛后，他上了车，开始不停地抱怨和呻吟。
How did it make you feel when the ref made those calls?
裁判做出那些判罚时，你感觉怎么样？
Very mad.
非常生气。
Do you feel any better now?
你现在感觉好点了吗？
No.
没有。
Tell me how it feels.
告诉我那是种什么感觉。
It feels like someone keeps poking you in the back of the shoulder and then saying, foul, foul, foul, foul.
感觉就像有人不断地戳你的后肩，然后说，犯规，犯规，犯规，犯规。
Have you ever fouled out in your career?
你的生涯中有过被罚出场吗？
No.
没有。
Did you know that you were at risk of fouling out?
你知道你有被罚出场的风险吗？
Yes, but I also knew if I did, it would be unfair because I knew that he was calling the stupidest fouls. He'll look back and say, oh, I was being a huge-- asshole.
知道，但我也知道如果我被罚出场，那是不公平的，因为我知道他在吹一些极其愚蠢的犯规。他会回头说，噢，我当时表现得像个超级——混蛋。
Klay with the steal. Klay in a footrace. Cousins trying to catch him. He can't! Klay with a very deep three.
克莱抢断。克莱在赛跑。考辛斯试图追上他。他做不到！克莱超远三分。
The thing is, I know why my son does what he does. He thinks he's Klay Thompson, the all-star shooting guard of the Golden State Warriors.
问题在于，我知道我儿子为什么要那样做。他以为他是克莱·汤普森，金州勇士队的全明星得分后卫。
They reset back to Thompson. Three-pointer-- bang.
他们重新把球传回给汤普森。三分球——进了。
When Klay hits a three, Klay pounds his chest and points to the sky. And so when Walker Lewis hits a three, he too pounds his chest and points to the sky.
当克莱投进三分时，克莱会拍拍胸口并指向天空。所以当沃克·刘易斯投进三分时，他也拍拍胸口指向天空。
And I think we have a technical foul as well. On Klay-- very unusual.
我想我们还有一个技术犯规。判给克莱——非常罕见。
When Klay is called for a foul, he scowls and throws up his arms in astonishment, and sometimes even says something to the ref that gets him slapped with a technical foul.
当克莱被吹犯规时，他会皱起眉头，惊愕地举起手臂，有时甚至对裁判说些什么，导致他被判技术犯规。
He only had one during the entire regular season.
他在整个常规赛期间只得到过一次。
And Klay's the famously most laid back all-star in the entire National Basketball Association.
而且克莱是整个国家篮球协会中众所周知的最随和的全明星球员。
Something has happened in the relationship between referees and players over the last, I guess, year or two.
在过去的一两年里，裁判和球员之间的关系发生了一些变化。
That's Ramona Shelburne. She's covered the NBA for the last decade for ESPN.
那是拉莫娜·谢尔本。她在ESPN报道NBA已经十年了。
It's been, quite frankly, ugly this year.
说实话，今年情况很糟糕。
One of the Warriors head-butted a ref. Another chucked his disgusting mouth guard off a ref's chest.
一名勇士队球员用头撞了裁判。另一名球员把恶心的牙套扔在了裁判的胸口上。
And Curry has been thrown out of the game.
库里也被赶出了比赛。
And some of the stuff I've seen, I mean, when Draymond Green is getting fined for calling Lauren Holtkamp a-- can we cuss on your podcast?
而且我看到的一些事情，我的意思是，当德雷蒙德·格林因为称呼劳伦·霍尔特坎普为——我们可以在你的播客里骂人吗？
I think we already have.
我想我们已经骂过了。
You know, a fucking bitch-- like, when he is saying that to a female referee, man, that's next level. And I haven't seen that before this season. It's the stars now who are really pushing the issue, right? It's Kevin Durant getting thrown out of games. It's Steph Curry getting thrown out.
你知道，一个他妈的婊子——当他那样称呼一位女裁判时，伙计，那真是太离谱了。在这个赛季之前我没见过这种情况。现在是球星们在推动这个问题，对吧？是凯文·杜兰特被赶出比赛。是斯蒂芬·库里被赶出比赛。
And the Golden State Warriors have completely unraveled.
而且金州勇士队彻底失控了。
Last year, bad behavior got various Golden State Warriors tossed out of 10 different basketball games. Kevin Durant, their best player, got thrown out of five-- four more than he'd been thrown out of his entire career up to that point. The men who coach the stars aren't much better. Even Steve Kerr, the Warriors' famously decent, civic-minded coach--
去年，糟糕的行为导致各种金州勇士队球员在10场不同的篮球比赛中被罚出场。凯文·杜兰特，他们最好的球员，被罚出场5次——比他职业生涯至今的总和还要多出4次。执教这些球星的人也好不到哪儿去。即使是史蒂夫·科尔，勇士队出了名的正派、有公民意识的教练——
I can snap. I can completely lose it.
我会抓狂。我会彻底失控。
If you back away from the Golden State Warriors, I mean, they're exemplars of the way people should behave. Especially your stars, they're, like, impeccably behaved people. I'm so pleased to have my son emulating your players. The only time they have problems really is with referees.
如果你退后一步观察金州勇士队，他们是人们应该如何表现的典范。尤其是你的球星们，他们表现得非常无可挑剔。我很高兴我的儿子效仿你们的球员。他们真正遇到问题的唯一时候就是面对裁判。
Yeah.
是的。
I can't imagine you in your life have another relationship like you have with referees.
我无法想象你在生活中还会和裁判有其他关系。
No, you're right. You're right. I would never say the things that I do to referees to a person in normal life. It happens two or three times a year. I've been caught on camera, you know, MF-ing a ref. And, you know, my daughter will send me a text, like Dad, what are you doing? It's all over Twitter. I can read your lips. This is embarrass-- and I'm embarrassed.
不，你是对的。你是对的。在正常生活中，我绝不会对别人说那些我对裁判说的话。这种情况一年发生两三次。我被摄像机拍到过，你知道，我骂裁判。而且，我的女儿会发短信给我，说爸爸，你在干嘛？推特上到处都是。我能读你的唇语。这太尴尬了——而我也感到很尴尬。
So why is that? It's a sense of right or wrong. You know, I feel like there's this personal offense, like something unfair is happening.
所以这是为什么呢？这是一种对与错的观念。你知道，我感觉这是一种个人冒犯，好像有什么不公平的事情正在发生。
The players get fined if they talk about the refs, so we won't be talking to them. But it's not just them or their coaches or my son who are treating refs in ways they'd never treat an ordinary person. It's the fans in every arena who spend meaningful amounts of their time looking for the refs' mistakes on the JumboTron. It's the cable sports channels playing and replaying the refs' mistakes so their viewers can tweet and retweet about them. It's this entire infrastructure, seemingly built to focus attention on whatever mistakes the refs make for the sole purpose of generating outrage.
球员如果谈论裁判会被罚款，所以我们不会跟他们谈论。但不仅仅是他们或他们的教练或我的儿子在以一种他们绝不会对待普通人的方式对待裁判。在每个竞技场里，都有球迷花费大量的时间在场馆大屏幕上寻找裁判的失误。是有线体育频道反复播放裁判的失误，让观众在推特上转发和评论。这是一个庞大的基础设施，似乎专门为了聚焦裁判犯下的任何错误而建立，唯一的目的就是制造愤怒。
(CHANTING) Ref, you suck! Ref, you suck! Ref, you suck! Ref, you suck!
（呼喊）裁判，你烂透了！裁判，你烂透了！裁判，你烂透了！裁判，你烂透了！
If there's one thing that unites Americans just now, it's their belief that the refs suck-- which is weird, because they almost certainly suck less than ever before. Before you hate me for saying that, give me a moment to show why.
如果说现在有什么能团结美国人的话，那就是他们认为裁判烂透了——这很奇怪，因为他们几乎可以肯定比以往任何时候都做得好。在你因为我这么说而讨厌我之前，让我花点时间展示一下原因。
So we're walking across a parking lot in Secaucus, New Jersey. And there are chain hotels and motels in someone's idea of a mall. And we're surrounded on all sides by freeways. It's like what people think about when they tell jokes about New Jersey. And we're approaching a four-story, rectangular, otherwise nondescript concrete building.
我们在新泽西州锡考克斯的一个停车场里走。周围是连锁酒店和汽车旅馆，位于某人构思的商场里。我们四面被高速公路包围。就像人们讲新泽西笑话时想到的那样。我们正在接近一栋四层楼高的矩形建筑，外观普通。
There's a discreet little sign here that says NBA and shows a logo with a basketball player. Inside, a recent concession to the world we live in-- the Replay Center, a place where basketball referees review the calls made by other basketball referees in real time, to minimize referee error. The Replay Center was built to persuade people that life was fair.
这里有个不显眼的小牌子，上面写着NBA，还有一个篮球运动员的标志。里面，是为我们生活的世界所做的近期让步——回放中心，一个篮球裁判实时审核其他篮球裁判判罚的地方，旨在最大限度地减少裁判失误。回放中心的建立是为了让人们相信生活是公平的。
And the door is locked.
而且门是锁着的。
Someone eventually unlocks the door and leads me down a hall filled with a lot of old basketball stuff-- jerseys and bobbleheads and basketballs and posters of Michael Jordan. The Replay Center was the ultimate man cave--
最后有人打开了门，领我走进一个走廊，里面摆满了许多老旧的篮球物品——球衣、摇头娃娃、篮球和迈克尔·乔丹的海报。回放中心是终极男性洞穴——
Ultimate man cave, right?
终极男性洞穴，对吧？
It's also the latest weapon in the battle for fairness.
它也是追求公平战斗中的最新武器。
So this place, just on first view, is amazing.
所以这个地方，第一眼看上去，真是令人惊叹。
It really is.
确实如此。
It's wall-to-wall screens, 110 of them. What's on them is whatever is captured by all the cameras in 29 NBA arenas across the country. They may have a screen somewhere with scores on it, but I didn't see it. And they're all muted. What you hear is referees staring at basketball games. What you see is nothing but angles on professional basketball courts.
它布满了屏幕，一共有110个。上面显示的是全国29个NBA场馆内所有摄像机捕捉到的画面。他们可能在某个地方有个显示比分的屏幕，但我没看见。而且它们全部都是静音的。你听到的是裁判盯着篮球比赛的声音。你看到的是专业篮球场上无尽的角度。
Nobody's ever walked in here and walked out and said, this place sucks.
从来没有人走进来走出去后说，这个地方糟透了。
That's Joe Borgia, who's run the center since 2014. Before he volunteered for Secaucus duty, he refereed NBA games. His father was an NBA ref before him. With a break in the late '60s, a Borgia has been reffing professional basketball games since 1946.
那是乔·博尔吉亚，他自2014年以来一直负责这个中心。在志愿服务锡考克斯之前，他曾担任NBA裁判。他的父亲在他之前也是一名NBA裁判。除了60年代末的短暂中断，博尔吉亚家族自1946年以来一直有人在执裁职业篮球比赛。
If you went back to your dad at the beginning of his career and said, this is what it's going to look like, what do you think he'd have said?
如果你回到你父亲职业生涯的早期说，未来会变成这样，你认为他会怎么说？
If I told him we would have replay, he'd turn over in his grave, forget about a replay center.
如果我告诉他我们会使用回放，他会从坟墓里跳出来，别提什么回放中心了。
Is that right?
是这样吗？
Oh, absolutely.
噢，绝对。
You see, the refs used to insist on their authority. And everyone agreed that there was no better way to ensure the fairness of the game than to let the ref play god. The Replay Center is an admission that the ref is not god, that he makes mistakes.
你看，裁判过去坚持他们的权威。每个人都同意，确保比赛公平的最好方法就是让裁判扮演上帝。回放中心是一个承认，承认裁判不是上帝，他会犯错。
I think the mention of replay, none of us liked it when we first heard it. It's a necessary evil. It's necessary. You have to have it today.
我认为提到回放时，我们刚听说时都不喜欢它。这是必要的恶。它是必要的。今天你必须拥有它。
Everything is taped now. Everyone pays more attention to the referees' mistakes. So the NBA has to as well. Now, when a ref thinks he might have screwed up some call or didn't get a good look at the action--
现在一切都被录了下来。每个人都更加关注裁判的失误。所以NBA也必须关注。现在，当裁判认为他可能搞砸了某次判罚，或者没有看清楚动作——
Watch the referee on the bottom of the screen.
看屏幕底部的裁判。
--he twirls his fingers in the air.
——他会在空中转动手指。
There's your signal.
这就是信号。
That's the signal to the ref in the Replay Center, who goes to work, reviewing the tape, looking for the best angle to figure out what actually happened.
那是给回放中心裁判的信号，他们开始工作，审阅录像，寻找最佳角度来判断到底发生了什么。
Sure, Dick. We're going to give you two good angles, all right? That's the first one. The other one's going to give you a better look.
当然，迪克。我们会给你两个好的角度，好吗？这是第一个。另一个会给你更好的视野。
The refs here sit dressed in black staring at screens, waiting for a signal from somewhere in America. The end of games is when they get most involved, because that's when fans and coaches and players are most likely to accuse some ref of having made the mistake that changed the outcome. Of course, a mistake at the beginning has just as much effect on a game as a mistake at the end, but the end is what people notice and get outraged about. So the justice at the end of the game must be more exact than it is at the beginning.
这里的裁判身着黑色服装，盯着屏幕，等待着来自美国某处的信号。比赛末段是他们参与最多的时候，因为那时球迷、教练和球员最有可能指责某个裁判犯了改变结果的错误。当然，开始时的错误和结束时的错误对比赛有同样的影响，但人们注意并感到愤怒的是结尾。因此，比赛结束时的正义必须比开始时更精确。
These Replay Center refs have video technicians with them, who can freeze a moment on screen, then zoom out or zoom in so that the entire screen contains only a player's fingertips or his toes. Here you just scroll through tiny slivers of the game, not the game itself. The sliver is where injustices might occur.
这些回放中心的裁判配有视频技术员，他们可以将屏幕上的瞬间冻结，然后放大或缩小，以至于整个屏幕只包含一名球员的指尖或脚趾。在这里你只是浏览比赛的小碎片，而不是比赛本身。这些碎片就是可能发生不公正的地方。
I mean, goodness gracious, if you don't have slow motion in here or freeze frame, it's very difficult.
我的意思是，天哪，如果你在这里没有慢动作或定格，那真的非常困难。
Of course, in slow motion, you can see things that the naked eye misses. Magicians sometimes perform during halftimes of the NBA games. When Joe Borgia slows it down, he can see how they do their tricks. It's kind of the same thing with the players.
当然，在慢动作中，你可以看到肉眼错过的东西。魔术师有时会在NBA比赛的中场休息时表演。当乔·博尔吉亚放慢速度时，他就能看清他们是如何表演把戏的。球员的情况也是一样的。
Exactly. I can go 1/60 of a second at a time. You're gonna pick a lot of little things up.
没错。我可以一次以1/60秒的速度进行。你会发现很多小细节。
So what these players have gotten good at is creating optical illusions. And then--
所以这些球员擅长的是制造光学错觉。然后——
Of course.
当然。
The sort of things that a magician does.
魔术师所做的那类事情。
Well, isn't flopping an optical illusion?
嗯，假摔不就是一种光学错觉吗？
Flopping is what they call it when a player pretends to have been knocked over by another player. Tricking the refs into making bad calls is now considered a skill.
假摔是指球员假装被另一名球员撞倒。欺骗裁判做出错误的判罚现在被视为一种技能。
For possible flagrant?
为了可能的恶意犯规？
There's blood on the screens. Kevin Love's front tooth got knocked in. Love plays for the Cleveland Cavaliers. And the question is, did the guy who popped him in the mouth do it intentionally?
屏幕上有血。凯文·乐福的前门牙被打掉了。乐福为克利夫兰骑士队效力。问题是，那个打在他嘴上的人是有意的吗？
We're looking for the unnatural. Did he throw his elbow out?
我们在寻找不自然的东西。他肘部挥出来了吗？
The refs need to decide if the violence was not just excessive but unsportsmanlike, which sounds archaic, because we've sort of lost the concept.
裁判需要判断这种暴力不仅是过度的，而且是不符合体育道德的，这听起来很陈旧，因为我们似乎已经失去了这个概念。
Did he lead--
他领导了吗——
But the foul was on Kevin Love. I thought he was outside--
但犯规判给了凯文·乐福。我认为他在外侧——
Yeah, but he was moved.
是的，但他被移动了。
He was moved.
他被移动了。
He was late. Come on, you gotta be quick on these.
他晚了。来吧，你在这方面得快点。
I'm still stuck on the blood coming out of his mouth.
我还在纠结他嘴里流出的血。
Yeah, I know. It's ugly.
是的，我知道。这很丑陋。
The players all stand around scratching themselves while the refs put on headsets and talk to the Replay Center.
当裁判戴上耳机与回放中心交谈时，球员们都站在一边抓挠自己。
So the blood doesn't sway the decision?
所以血迹不会影响决定？
Listen, there's a lot of contact. A lot of it's accidental. That was accidental.
听着，有很多身体接触。很多都是意外。那是意外。
The only thing stopping the Replay Center from checking every decision is that it slows the game down. Here in Secaucus, they're still trying to figure out how they might talk to the refs as they run up and down the court. Because if they could do that, they could just fix every call on the fly.
阻止回放中心检查每一个判罚的唯一原因是它会拖慢比赛节奏。在这里，在锡考克斯，他们仍在研究如何在裁判在场上跑动时与他们交谈。因为如果他们能做到这一点，他们就可以直接现场纠正每一个判罚。
The special forces, we found that we actually use a chip over the molar that worked off the vibration of the bone. Believe it or not, we did. We got a handful of G League referees molded, and we tested that.
特种部队，我们发现我们实际上使用了一个覆盖在磨牙上的芯片，通过骨骼振动工作。信不信由你，我们真的用了。我们让几个G联盟的裁判戴上并进行了测试。
To wear a chip over their molar?
佩戴覆盖在磨牙上的芯片？
But it wasn't good enough, because they didn't know where the voice was coming from.
但那不够好，因为他们不知道声音是从哪里来的。
It was just a voice in their heads?
那只是他们脑子里的一个声音？
They didn't know where it was. Was that a coach talking to me?
他们不知道那是哪里来的。那是教练在跟我说话吗？
It's insane. The time and money now being spent to ensure the fairness of what, after all, is just a basketball game-- a bajillion miles of fiber optic cable connect this room directly to the NBA arenas around the country, all for two calls a game.
这太疯狂了。现在投入时间和金钱来确保公平——毕竟这只是一场篮球比赛——数以亿计的光纤电缆直接将这个房间连接到全国各地的NBA场馆，全部只是为了每场比赛的两次判罚。
At two calls a game-- $15 million to build this room to get two calls during the game. But you gotta do it. You gotta do it.
每场比赛两次判罚——花1500万美元建这个房间，只是为了在比赛中得到两次判罚。但你必须这样做。你必须这样做。
Can I just pause here a moment, just to consider what the NBA has done in the past few years to improve the calls? For example, they've brought in serious managers to hire and train the refs.
我能暂停一下吗，只是为了考虑NBA过去几年为了改进判罚所做的事情？例如，他们引入了认真的经理来聘请和培训裁判。
Joe Borgia calls his boss the general, because she actually was a general and an Air Force pilot. Her name is Michelle Johnson, and before she supervised NBA refs, she ran the Air Force Academy. It sounds like overkill to use a general to make sure basketball games are well reffed. But the NBA thought it needed overkill.
乔·博尔吉亚称他的老板为将军，因为她确实是一位将军和空军飞行员。她的名字叫米歇尔·约翰逊，在监管NBA裁判之前，她管理着空军学院。用将军来确保篮球比赛裁判执裁得当听起来像是大材小用。但NBA认为它需要大材小用。
So adjust your mic a little bit.
所以把你的麦克风调整一下。
Or at least Adam Silver, the NBA commissioner did.
或者至少NBA总裁亚当·肖华是这么想的。
If people don't believe that the league office is unbiased and that the officials are unbiased, you're going to have a problem regardless of the accuracy of the calls.
如果人们不相信联盟办公室是公正的，也不相信官员是公正的，那么无论判罚准确与否，你都会有麻烦。
People watching at home are scrutinizing every call on their phones and their TVs. They had just enough information to be suspicious of the league.
在家观看的人正在用手机和电视审视每一个判罚。他们掌握了足够的信息来怀疑联盟。
There's 18 cameras covering every game, that there's 18,000 people watching games with sophisticated smartphones that have high definition audio and video. We started to get into trouble.
每场比赛有18个摄像机覆盖，有18000人拿着拥有高清音频和视频的先进智能手机观看比赛。我们开始遇到麻烦了。
Silver took over in 2014 and also hired Joe Borgia to run the Replay Center. Since then, he's taken a ridiculous amount of grief, just for trying to improve the justice on a basketball court.
肖华于2014年接任，并聘请了乔·博尔吉亚负责回放中心。从那时起，他仅仅因为试图改善篮球场上的正义就承受了巨大的痛苦。
So here's what else Silver's done. He's broadened the pool of people from which refs are selected. They used to be mostly white men, mostly from the same background. At one point, four NBA refs came from the same high school. He's hired more black refs and female refs.
所以肖华还做了这些。他扩大了裁判选拔的范围。他们过去大多是白人男性，大多来自相同的背景。有一次，四名NBA裁判来自同一所高中。他雇用了更多的黑人裁判和女性裁判。
He's insisted that referees be physically fit so they can get into position to see all the plays. While everyone else in America is getting fatter, the refs are getting buff. They're also now getting new feedback on all their bad calls. Silver decided to publish the mistakes made by every ref in the last two minutes of every game so everyone could see them. He gives the teams and the refs a private document listing every refereeing mistake.
他坚持要求裁判保持良好的身体素质，以便他们能到位看到所有的比赛。当美国其他人都变得越来越胖时，裁判们却变得越来越壮。他们现在还针对自己所有的错误判罚得到了新的反馈。肖华决定公布每场比赛最后两分钟裁判犯下的错误，以便每个人都能看到。他给球队和裁判一份私密文件，列出每一个裁判失误。
All this new data on refs means that we and they know all sorts of strange things about their minds. For instance, we now know that their calls have tended to favor whichever team is losing. Their calls also favor the home team. Some large part of home court advantage is just the refs.
关于裁判的所有这些新数据意味着我们和他们都知道关于他们思维的各种奇怪的事情。例如，我们现在知道他们的判罚倾向于支持落后的一方。他们的判罚也偏向主队。主场优势很大一部分只是裁判因素。
The analytics department of the Houston Rockets has even done a study that shows that the home team that gets the best calls is the Utah Jazz. Why Utah? Who knows? But you can be sure that someone will figure that out. There's now basically a small army of geeks analyzing all this new data.
休斯顿火箭队的分析部门甚至做了一项研究，显示获得最好判罚的主队是犹他爵士队。为什么是犹他？谁知道呢？但你可以肯定会有人找出原因。现在基本上有一支小型的书呆子大军在分析所有这些新数据。
Look, I don't really like writing papers about sports. I'd prefer to write about the economy.
看，我真的不喜欢写关于体育的论文。我更倾向于写关于经济的。
That's Justin Wolfers, a behavioral economist at the University of Michigan, and the co-author of a paper about NBA refs.
那是贾斯汀·沃尔弗斯，密歇根大学的行为经济学家，也是一篇关于NBA裁判论文的合著者。
But the thing is, this is a domain where the NBA referees have tremendous incentives not to make the wrong call. Every error they make is tracked. Those errors determine whether they get more games. Those games determine how much they get paid. This is arguably the most analyzed workforce in the country.
但问题是，这是一个NBA裁判极度没有动力去做错误判罚的领域。他们犯下的每一个错误都被追踪。这些错误决定了他们是否能获得更多的比赛。那些比赛决定了他们能挣多少钱。这可以说是全国受分析程度最高的劳动力群体。
Basketball referees are now picked apart in ways that not long ago would have seemed preposterous-- not just for the fairness of their calls but for their unconscious behavior. Wolfers took data from over a decade of NBA basketball games, more than 250,000 of them. Then he set out to look for evidence of the refs' racial bias.
篮球裁判现在被分析的方式在不久前看来是荒谬的——不仅是因为他们判罚的公平性，还因为他们的无意识行为。沃尔弗斯使用了十多年NBA篮球比赛的数据，超过25万场比赛的数据。然后他着手寻找裁判种族偏见的证据。
The question here isn't whether people are anti-black or anti-white but whether there's an in-group bias. So if a predominately black team is playing and the refereeing crew is predominantly white, are there more fouls called against them than on nights when the same team is playing with a predominantly black refereeing crew? And it turns out, the answer is yes.
这里的问题不是人们是否反黑或反白，而是是否存在群体内偏见。所以如果一个以黑人为主的球队在比赛，而裁判组以白人为主，那么与同一支球队在以黑人为主的裁判组执裁的夜晚相比，他们被吹的犯规是否更多？结果证明，答案是肯定的。
Wolfers wrote his paper back in 2007, before this new age of referee transparency.
沃尔弗斯在2007年写了他的论文，在裁判透明度这个新时代之前。
Well, it was a bit of a lesson for me. You can probably tell by my accent, Michael, I'm an Australian. You know, I thought it was an interesting piece of social science. It turned out The New York Times put it on the front page.
嗯，这对我来说是个教训。你可能通过我的口音听出来了，迈克尔，我是澳大利亚人。你知道，我以为这是一个有趣的社会科学片段。结果《纽约时报》把它放在了头版。
And the NBA wasn't happy. The commissioner at the time attacked the study and embarrassed the league by trying and failing to refute its findings.
而NBA并不高兴。当时的总裁攻击了这项研究，并试图推翻其结论但失败了，让联盟感到尴尬。
This morning we'll hear from the NBA commissioner, David Stern.
今天早上我们将听到NBA总裁大卫·斯特恩的发言。
Our referees are the most reviewed, most ranked, and most rated. And that's why we take exception to what The Times did here.
我们的裁判是最受审查、排名和评级的。这就是为什么我们对《时报》在这里所做的事情提出异议。
That's Stern on NPR in 2007. The result of all this coverage, every single referee was made aware of his unconscious bias. When the dust settled, Justin Wolfers was curious to know if his paper had had any effect. He made another study of referees after the controversy he'd created. And guess what.
那是2007年斯特恩在NPR上的发言。所有这些报道的结果是，每一位裁判都意识到了自己的无意识偏见。当尘埃落定后，贾斯汀·沃尔弗斯好奇地想知道他的论文是否产生了任何影响。他在引发争议后又对裁判进行了另一项研究。你猜怎么着。
The most recent study that we did seems to suggest that that form of racial bias has gone away.
我们所做的最新研究似乎表明，那种形式的种族偏见已经消失了。
For a while anyway. He has no idea why. Maybe simply making the refs aware of the problem was enough to correct it. By the way, the NBA disputes this study too. But in the end, this became a case study-- not in ref ineptitude but in ref reform. NBA refs have now achieved what police forces can only dream of, though the refs have no choice. The world's now too good at seeing their mistakes.
至少有一段时间。他不知道为什么。也许仅仅让裁判意识到这个问题就足以纠正它了。顺便说一下，NBA也质疑这项研究。但最终，这成为了一个案例研究——不是关于裁判的无能，而是关于裁判的改革。NBA裁判现在实现了警察部队只能梦想的目标，尽管裁判别无选择。现在全世界都太擅长发现他们的错误了。
Look, there's no way any basketball referee is going to be perfect. But there's also no way these refs are anything but more accurate than they've ever been. I mean, even home court advantage means less than it used to. And yet these refs are treated as if they're trying to rig the games.
看，没有任何篮球裁判是完美的。但也绝不可能这些裁判做得比以往任何时候都差。我的意思是，即使是主场优势也比以前少多了。然而这些裁判被对待得好像他们试图操纵比赛一样。
(CHANTING) Ref, you suck! Ref, you suck! Ref, you suck! Ref, you suck! Ref, you suck!
（呼喊）裁判，你烂透了！裁判，你烂透了！裁判，你烂透了！裁判，你烂透了！裁判，你烂透了！
The sound of those 18,000 people screaming at you or booing you, does it sound any different than it sounded when you started?
听到那18000人对你尖叫或嘘你，它听起来和你开始时有什么不同吗？
Yeah. There's a little more anger involved. And, you know, it used to be, sort of, of the garden variety. You're terrible, you suck, any of those kinds of terms.
是的。涉及了更多的愤怒。而且，你知道，过去那种通常是普通类型的。你很糟糕，你烂透了，任何这类词汇。
That's Monty McCutchen, who started reffing in 1993, and so got to see firsthand the effect that the arrival of the internet has had on referees.
那是蒙蒂·麦卡琴，他在1993年开始执裁，因此亲眼目睹了互联网的到来对裁判产生的影响。
A few years back, twitter exploded in game five of the Miami Heat and Oklahoma City Thunder finals from years ago.
几年前，推特在热火和雷霆的总决赛第五场中爆发了。
One of the players hit a three point shot. McCutchen was giving the signal for three and running to beat the players back to the other end of the court when he realized he had lost his balance.
一名球员投中了一个三分球。麦卡琴正在给出三分信号，并跑向另一端以赶在球员之前，这时他意识到自己失去了平衡。
Falling for a referee, it doesn't get much more embarrassing than that. It's bad. People are on you pretty good, you know. And I'm trying to hold it up, and Erik was on the sideline. And he sees me fall.
对于裁判来说，跌倒没有什么比这更尴尬的了。这很糟糕。人们对你很严厉，你知道。我正试图支撑住，埃里克在场边。他看到我摔倒了。
Erik is Erik Spoelstra, the Miami Heat coach.
埃里克是埃里克·斯波尔斯特拉，迈阿密热火队的教练。
And he sort of just stood onto the floor and braced me. And our arms sort of interlocked as he braced me, righted me. I yell out, thanks, as I go on by, and I run on down to the baseline. After the game, Twitter exploded that the NBA is rigged. If you don't believe that watch Monty McCutchen give a high five to Erik Spoelstra after this three.
他只是站到地板上扶住了我。当我们扶住我时，我们的手臂缠在一起，把我扶正了。我路过时大喊一声谢谢，然后跑向底线。赛后，推特上关于NBA是被操纵的言论爆发了。如果你不相信，看看蒙蒂·麦卡琴在这个三分球后和埃里克·斯波尔斯特拉击掌。
And the reality of that was just so far and away wrong up against this real human moment of just a reactionary thing that a good person does for another good person. You see someone falling, you help them not fall.
而那件事的真相与那种好的对他人的那种人反应性的真实人类时刻相比，实在是太错误了。你看到有人摔倒，你帮助他们不摔倒。
He says that when he started out reffing, no one would have even noticed. And if they did, it wouldn't have mattered. That's changed.
他说当他刚开始执裁时，没人会注意。即便他们注意到了，也无所谓。这种情况已经改变了。
Mistakes get made as NBA referees. And they're just mistakes. But they often get interpreted in this wider scheme of thought process that a lot of our cultures is dealing with right now, which is, there must be a fix in. There must be a reason for this.
作为NBA裁判，错误总是会犯的。它们只是错误。但它们经常被解释为我们许多文化现在正在处理的更广泛的过程思维方案的一部分，那就是，肯定有什么猫腻。肯定有个原因。
Do you think the world is looking for a fix more now than it was when you started?
你认为世界现在比你刚开始的时候更在寻找猫腻吗？
I think that the t-shirt I saw recently has merit-- "I'm not saying it's your fault. I'm saying I'm blaming you."
我认为我最近看到的T恤很有道理——“我不是说那是你的错。我说的是我在责怪你。”
You feel abused.
你感到被虐待了。
Yeah. Now, you know, people do their research. Things are out there on the internet. They know your record with their team. There's all these sites on all these different--
是的。现在，你知道，人们做他们的研究。网上的东西很多。他们知道你对他们球队的记录。有所有这些网站在所有这些不同的——
Do they know personal things about you?
他们知道关于你的私人信息吗？
Oh, sure. Of course, some death threats are made from time to time in playoff series, and you'll get security all the way to both the hotel and then the hotel the next morning out to the airport. That's a--
噢，当然。当然，季后赛中不时会有死亡威胁，你会有安保一直送到酒店，然后第二天早上从酒店送到机场。这是一个——
You have security to the hotel?
你有送到酒店的安保？
Not every night, but when those threats are a known factor-- it has happened in my career-- security to your car is mandatory every night.
不是每天晚上，但当那些威胁是一个已知的因素时——在我的职业生涯中确实发生过——每天晚上去你的车的安保是强制性的。
And at some point you feel this question rising up in you. In me it rose up while I was talking to Ramona Shelburne, the ESPN reporter.
在某个时刻，你感到这个问题在你心中升起。在我这里，它是在我和ESPN记者拉莫娜·谢尔本交谈时升起的。
Why would anybody want to be a ref?
为什么有人想当裁判？
Seriously. I wonder that too, man. I just-- you know, they're not allowed to say anything. They're not allowed to explain themselves. They're not allowed to defend themselves.
说真的。我也很好奇，伙计。我只是——你知道，他们不允许说任何话。他们不允许解释自己。他们不允许为自己辩护。
Look, obviously they get paid. They start at 150 grand a year. And if they're great at their job and work extra games, they can make as much as 500. But there are lots of ways to get paid without spending half your life in hotel rooms and the other half being insulted by arenas filled with crazy people.
看，很明显他们拿工资。他们起薪一年15万美元。如果他们工作出色且多执裁比赛，他们能挣到50万美元。但有很多挣钱的方法，而不需要把你的一半生命花在酒店房间里，另一半在挤满疯子的竞技场里被侮辱。
Do you think the refereeing has gotten worse or better?
你认为裁判工作变差了还是变好了？
I actually think it's gotten better.
我实际上认为它变好了。
Of course it's gotten better. How could it not have? The mystery is why the stars and the coaches and the fans act as if it's gotten worse. Sitting in the NBA replay center in Secaucus, New Jersey, I get a hunch about that. After I see all these people on all these TV screens jumping around and hollering at refs, the ruckus appears to be confined to Cleveland. But in here, it feels like the entire universe is disturbed. There's a reason for this. LeBron James is upset.
当然变好了。怎么可能不呢？谜团是为什么球星、教练和球迷表现得好像它变差了。坐在新泽西州锡考克斯的NBA回放中心，我对这一点有了预感。在我看到所有这些在电视屏幕上蹦蹦跳跳、对着裁判大喊大叫的人之后，喧闹似乎仅限于克利夫兰。但在里面，感觉整个宇宙都被扰动了。这有一个原因。勒布朗·詹姆斯生气了。
See? He's arguing. There he goes. LeBron James is going from ref to ref. He seems to know which refs to argue with.
看？他在争论。他去了。勒布朗·詹姆斯正在一个裁判接一个裁判地吵。他似乎知道该和哪些裁判争论。
Yeah, they're talking about goaltending. So they're talking about it, they're talking about. I think they might change. So James is-- James and the other guy had the best angle.
是的，他们在谈论干扰球。所以他们在谈论它，他们谈论着。我想他们可能会改变判罚。所以詹姆斯是——詹姆斯和另一个人有最好的视角。
Do you think that LeBron James has any effect doing that?
你认为勒布朗·詹姆斯这样做有任何影响吗？
Um--
嗯——
The ref in Cleveland is not twirling his finger. There's no signal to us to do anything in the Replay Center. LeBron's drama, strictly speaking, is pointless. It's strange the way these players argue. They must think that if they make life unpleasant enough for the ref, he'll think twice before the next call.
克利夫兰的裁判没有转动手指。回放中心没有信号让我们做任何事。勒布朗的戏剧，严格来说，毫无意义。这些球员争论的方式很奇怪。他们一定认为如果他们让裁判的生活足够不愉快，他在下一次判罚前会三思而后行。
They didn't review it.
他们没有回放。
Well, it's not reviewable.
嗯，这是不可回放的。
Goaltending is not reviewable?
干扰球不可回放？
Only in the last two minutes. Come on, Michael. Get a--
只有在最后两分钟。来吧，迈克尔。搞清楚——
Sorry.
抱歉。
It's then that it occurs to me, just looking around the room at 110 TV screens, I've had a hard time following the games, never mind the scores. I sometimes don't even know which teams are playing. But every time a player gets up into a referee's face, I've recognized the player. And I actually don't know that many NBA players, but I know all the ones who pitch these hissy fits, because the only players getting up into the faces of the refs are the famous players, or the coaches who protect them.
就在那时我意识到了，环顾四周110个电视屏幕，我很难跟着比赛节奏，更别说比分了。我有时甚至不知道是哪些球队在打。但每次有球员冲到裁判面前时，我都能认出那个球员。而我其实并不认识那么多NBA球员，但我知道所有那些大吵大闹的球员，因为只有那些著名的球员，或者保护他们的教练才会冲到裁判面前。
Ramona Shelburne put her finger on it. The more aggressive behavior towards refs isn't coming from every player. It's coming from the stars.
拉莫娜·谢尔本指出了这一点。对裁判更具侵略性的行为并不是来自所有球员。它来自球星。
It's just different than in the past. Like, you know, when you're a star, I think there's this feeling that you've sort of risen above reproach. You get used to a certain level of treatment. You get used to people who treat you that way. And then you feel like you should be treated that way.
这和过去不同。就像，你知道，当你是一个球星时，我认为有一种感觉，你已经超脱了批评。你习惯了某种程度的待遇。你习惯了人们那样对待你。然后你觉得你应该得到那种对待。
Yeah. So a referee-- a referee to that person comes as a shock.
是的。所以裁判——对于那个人来说，裁判就是一个冲击。
Oh, yeah. You know, with any star and any celebrity, there comes a level of entitlement. So anybody who goes against that, who doesn't treat you like a star, gets put into that hater category.
噢，是的。你知道，对于任何球星和任何名人来说，都伴随着一种权利感。所以任何与此对立、不把你当球星看的人，都会被归入仇恨者类别。
You want to understand the way the refs are treated? Stop thinking of them as people just doing their best to try to make a game fair, and start thinking of them as haters.
你想理解裁判被对待的方式吗？停止把他们看作是尽力让比赛公平的人，把他们看作是仇恨者。
So we just got really interested in a very simple question of, does this sense of being privileged make you disobey the rules of the road or the laws of the land.
所以我们只是对一个非常简单的问题产生了浓厚的兴趣，即，这种被优待的感觉是否会让你违反道路规则或国家法律。
That's Dacher Keltner. He's a professor of psychology at Cal Berkeley, and someone who wonders about the effect inequality has on people's behavior.
那是达切尔·克特纳。他是加州大学伯克利分校的心理学教授，也是一个对不平等如何影响人们行为感到好奇的人。
An experience I had at Berkeley where I was riding my bike up this hill. And I got to the four-way stop sign, and I was halfway through this four-way stop sign--
我在伯克利时的一次经历，我骑自行车上坡。我到了四向停车标志，我当时已经过了一半——
[MOTOR RUNNING]
[发动机运转声]
And this guy in a black Mercedes rolls through the stop sign, is halfway there, is a foot away from me about to take me out, and he's on his cell phone. And I looked at him. I was ready to take him on, like, all right, buddy, this is it. And what was most telling about this whole experience was he looked at me as if I was in the wrong and I should get out of his way, you know, even though I had made it through the stop sign first.
那个开黑色奔驰的家伙滚过了停车标志，走了一半，离我一英尺远，差点撞到我，而他还在打手机。我看着他。我准备和他对质，就像，好吧，伙计，就是这样。而这次经历中最说明问题的是，他看着我就好像我是错的一方，我应该给他让路，你知道，尽管我是第一个通过停车标志的人。
So Dacher and a colleague dreamed up this weird experiment. They hid two Berkeley undergraduates in the bushes near four-way stop signs. The undergrads noted the makes of all cars coming through the intersection, assigned them numbers, one to five, according to their market value. A new Mercedes was a five, a Honda was a three, and an old Pacer was a one.
所以达切尔和一位同事构想了这个奇怪的实验。他们把两名伯克利大学生藏在四向停车标志附近的灌木丛中。学生们记录了所有经过交叉路口的汽车品牌，根据它们的市场价值为它们分配数字，从一到五。新奔驰是5，本田是3，一辆旧帕瑟是1。
We positioned a Berkeley undergrad by a pedestrian zone, and we make sure they look like they want to cross the street. And they're sort of leaning into their pedestrian zone, where it's required by California law to stop.
我们将一名伯克利大学生安置在步行区，确保他们看起来想穿过街道。他们有点倾向于步行区，加州法律要求那里停车。
It's a game of one-on-one at a California crosswalk-- one car versus one pedestrian.
这是一场加州人行横道上的单挑比赛——一辆车对阵一个行人。
And 0% of the drivers of poor cars zoomed through the pedestrian zone. They all stopped. And 40-some odd percent-- 45% of the drivers of the fives, the rich cars, blazed through the pedestrian zone, and just say, the rules don't apply to me. I'll carry on.
而0%的低端车司机冲过了步行区。他们都停下了。而40多个百分点——45%的5分车，即豪车司机，呼啸着冲过步行区，只是说，规则不适用于我。我会继续走。
This one study led to a bunch of others that showed basically the same pattern of human behavior.
这项研究引导出了一系列其他研究，基本显示了同样的人类行为模式。
Another experiment, we bring people to the lab. And as they're leaving, there's this big bowl of candy. And it's like-- and it says on it, "for the children of the Institute of Human Development," on the bowl.
另一个实验，我们把人带到实验室。当他们离开时，有一个大碗糖果。上面写着，“为了人类发展研究所的孩子们”。
And we say, oh, you know, take a candy or two as you're leaving. And we count up how many candies they take after they leave the experiment. Privileged people grab a big handful of candy, compared to poorer people.
我们说，噢，你知道，离开时拿一两块糖果。我们数一下他们离开实验后拿了多少块。优待的人比起穷人会抓一大把糖果。
So let's turn the conversation to something much more important, which is basketball.
那么让我们把对话转向更重要的事情，也就是篮球。
Most important of all.
最重要的事情。
In the last five or six years, the NBA has embarked on essentially a dramatic reform of refereeing. At the same time, the friction between the players, and some of the owners, and some of the coaches, and the refs, is going through the roof.
在过去五六年里，NBA实质上启动了一场戏剧性的裁判改革。与此同时，球员、部分老板、教练和裁判之间的摩擦正在冲上云霄。
Wow.
哇。
The source of the outrage is the star players. The people who are getting thrown out of games are Kevin Durant and Steph Curry and James Harden. And the Warriors, the most famous team ever to walk on the court, are the chief culprits-- exhibit A in bad behavior towards refs. So you've got this weird combination.
愤怒的源头是球星球员。被踢出比赛的人是凯文·杜兰特、斯蒂芬·库里和詹姆斯·哈登。而勇士队，有史以来最著名的球队，是主要罪魁祸首——对待裁判行为不端的例证A。所以你得到了这个奇怪的组合。
Yeah. No, that's fascinating. I still remember being a Lakers fan-- you know, the great Magic Johnson teams. And watching Larry Bird do his nine-step lay-up. And I'm like, come on, make the call.
是的。不，这太迷人了。我仍然记得自己是个湖人球迷——你知道，伟大的魔术师约翰逊的球队。看着拉里·伯德做他的九步上篮。我想，来吧，判罚啊。
For most players of his era, that would have counted as traveling. But Larry Bird was like LeBron, the new Mercedes of his day. He played with certain assumptions about the rules and how they applied to him.
对于他那个时代的多数球员来说，那会被算作走步。但拉里·伯德就像勒布朗，他那个时代的奔驰。他带着关于规则以及它们如何适用于他的特定假设进行比赛。
The inequality on a basketball court--
篮球场上的不平等——
Is profound.
是深刻的。
--is profound. And it's more profound than it was in Larry Bird's era. Yeah Larry Bird was a millionaire. LeBron James might be a billionaire. And these guys are global franchises. So you got, in a funny way, a microcosm. It's an odd microcosm on a basketball court, of what's going on in the larger society.
——是深刻的。比拉里·伯德时代更深刻。是的，拉里·伯德是百万富翁。勒布朗·詹姆斯可能是亿万富翁。这些人是全球性的品牌。所以你以一种有趣的方式拥有了一个微观世界。篮球场上是一个奇怪的微观世界，反映了更广泛社会中发生的事情。
The NBA has set out to ref the games more objectively, more accurately, more fairly. This has enraged the stars and their fans and coaches. You want to know why? Here's what I think.
NBA已经着手更客观、更准确、更公平地执裁比赛。这激怒了球星、他们的球迷和教练。你想知道为什么吗？这就是我的想法。
The stars used to get more calls in their favor than they do now, just because they were stars. Objective refs have eliminated some of their privilege. The more objectivity there is, the less power they have. And to them, that's outrageous.
球星过去在判罚中获得的好处比现在多，仅仅因为他们是球星。客观的裁判消除了一些特权。客观性越多，他们的权力就越小。对他们来说，这太令人愤慨了。
I think American life just now has at least one thing in common with basketball-- the authority of its referees is under attack. If people don't trust the refs, one day you wake up in a world that seems not just unfair but actually sort of rigged-- that is, it's incapable of becoming fair because the people who benefit from the unfairness have the power to preserve it. Boom.
我想美国生活现在至少有一点和篮球共同之处——裁判的权威正在受到攻击。如果人们不信任裁判，总有一天你会醒来，发现世界不仅看起来不公平，而且实际上被操纵了——也就是说，它无法变得公平，因为受益于不公平的人有权力保护它。轰。
Do you flip a switch, and 110 screens go dark?
你拨动一个开关，110个屏幕就变黑了吗？
All the little small screens you gotta do manually. The big TVs we got the remote for.
所有那些小屏幕你得手动操作。大电视我们有遥控器。
Most nights, Joe Borgia stays at the Replay Center until almost 2:00 in the morning-- just him and a couple of refs staring at tiny slivers of basketball games, trying to impose justice on powerful people who don't want it.
大多数夜晚，乔·博尔吉亚留在锡考克斯的回放中心直到凌晨2点——只有他和几个裁判盯着篮球比赛的微小碎片，试图强行将正义施加给那些不想要它的强大人物。
They think I'm nuts. I am nuts. That's another story. All refs are nuts. You gotta be.
他们认为我疯了。我是疯了。那是另一个故事。所有裁判都疯了。你必须是。
You do?
你必须？
You have to be partially off. It's a 100% negative business.
你必须部分脱节。这是一个100%负面的行业。
100% negative business.
100%负面的行业。
That's why my son doesn't want to ref. Dad, I don't like people yelling at me.
这就是为什么我儿子不想当裁判。爸爸，我不喜欢人们对我大喊大叫。
One day a young Borgia naturally becomes a referee. The next, he doesn't. One day most people think the refs are more or less fair-- or at any rate, they don't spend a lot of time blaming them for all their problems. The next day, they wake up to radical inequality.
有一天年轻的博尔吉亚自然成为了一名裁判。第二天，他不再是了。有一天大多数人认为裁判或多或少是公平的——或者至少，他们不花时间把所有问题归咎于他们。第二天，他们醒来面对极端的不平等。
The people on top, the elites, think they're special. They behave as people do when they think they're special. Young people emulate them, without even thinking about it. They just assume that's how you act if you're a star or want to be.
顶层的人，精英们，认为自己很特别。当人们认为自己特别时，他们的行为也会随之改变。年轻人甚至在不假思索地模仿他们。他们只是假设如果你是一个球星或想成为球星，你就得那样表现。
My first question is-- why, when you hit a three point shot, which you often do, why in the past have you pounded your chest and pointed to the sky?
我的第一个问题是——为什么当你投中三分球时，你经常这样做，为什么过去你拍拍胸口并指向天空？
I did it because the people on the NBA-- in the NBA did it.
我这样做是因为NBA的人——在NBA里的人这样做。
What do you think they're doing? What does it mean?
你认为他们在做什么？那意味着什么？
I don't know. Just, like, I'm cool.
我不知道。只是，像，我很酷。
Do you believe in God?
你相信上帝吗？
No. I knew-- I mean, now I knew what it meant. But no, I don't.
不。我当时知道——我的意思是，现在我知道它的含义了。但没有，我不相信。
So what does it mean?
那么那意味着什么？
Basically, it's like, thank you, God.
基本上，它就像，谢谢你，上帝。
For hitting a three point shot? Do you think God was responsible when Klay Thompson hit a three point shot?
为了投进一个三分球？你认为当克莱·汤普森投进三分球时，是上帝的功劳吗？
To be honest, if God was watching over everybody whenever they hit a three point shot, I don't think that He would be able to, like, actually make them make the shot.
老实说，如果上帝在每个人投进三分球时都照看着，我不认为他能够，像，真的让他们投中那一球。
So do you have anything you'd like to say to the referees of the world before we turn this recording off?
所以你有什么想对世界裁判说的吗，在我们关掉录音之前？
Don't pick sides, unless it's my side.
别站队，除非是我的这一边。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Michael Lewis. His new podcast, Against The Rules, covers all kinds of institutions in America where people do not trust the refs anymore. It is made by Pushkin Industries. Find it wherever you get your podcasts.
迈克尔·刘易斯。他的新播客《规则之外》，涵盖了美国各种机构，人们不再信任那里的裁判。它由普希金工业公司制作。在你获取播客的地方都可以找到。
Coming up, a teenager grapples with the document that's supposed to enforce fairness above all others. I'm talking about the United States Constitution. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，一位青少年努力解读被认为旨在高于一切强制公平的文件。我说的是美国宪法。一分钟后，从芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "No Fair," stories about people young and old all over our country feeling a sense of injustice, feeling wronged, and not getting satisfaction from the people in charge. We have arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, The Fairer Sex. And for this act, let's go to Broadway. There's a show right now that starts with this true story.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，“不公平”，讲述了全国各地年轻人和老年人感受到不公正、感到受冤枉，并无法从负责人那里得到满意答复的故事。我们已经到达了节目的第二幕。第二幕，性别更公平。而对于这一幕，让我们去百老汇。现在有一部戏是以这个真实故事开头的。
When I was 15 years old, I would travel the country giving speeches about the Constitution at American Legion halls for prize money. This was a scheme invented by my mom to help me pay for college. I would travel to big cities like Denver and Fresno. I would give a speech, win a whole bunch of money, and then bring it back to put in my little safety deposit box for later.
当我15岁时，我会走遍全国在美国军团大厅演讲宪法，以获得奖金。这是我妈妈发明的一个方案，用来帮助我支付大学学费。我会去丹佛和弗雷斯诺这样的大城市。我会发表演讲，赢一大笔钱，然后带回来放进我的小保险箱留作后用。
This is Heidi Schreck in the show What the Constitution Means to Me. I loved this show. It's totally original in what it's about and in how it tells its story. It's very funny. It's a very patriotic show in this totally uncorny way.
这是海蒂·舒瑞克在《宪法对我意味着什么》这部剧中的表现。我非常喜欢这部剧。它在主题和讲述故事的方式上完全原创。它非常有趣。这是一部以完全不俗气的方式呈现的非常爱国的演出。
In the show, Heidi Schreck recreates the idealistic speech that she gave at 15 that won her enough money to pay for her whole college education. And then she talks about the Constitution and about her own life. Our show today is about fairness, and Heidi Schreck, to be clear, says that her 15-year-old self definitely saw the Constitution as a powerful instrument enforcing fairness.
在剧中，海蒂·舒瑞克重现了她15岁时发表的理想主义演讲，那次演讲为她赢得了足以支付全部大学教育的钱。然后她谈论了宪法和她自己的生活。我们今天的节目是关于公平的，海蒂·舒瑞克，明确地说，她15岁的自己绝对把宪法视为强制公平的强大工具。
I believed it made our country fairer, more equal, more democratic. I believed that wholeheartedly.
我相信它让我们的国家更公平、更平等、更民主。我全心全意地相信这一点。
At 15?
15岁时？
At 15.
15岁时。
Mm-hmm. You said that as a kid you had a crush on the Constitution.
嗯嗯。你说你小时候对宪法情有独钟。
(CHUCKLING) Yes.
（笑声）是的。
What does that mean?
那意味着什么？
I was really excited by it. I was a very idealistic, nerdy young person. And researching and reading about the Constitution-- my dad is a history teacher and talked very passionately about the genius of this document and its ability to evolve and to somehow surpass and rectify the flaws of its founders. Like, this idea that there was a document that could be created by flawed people that could be better than the people who made it.
我对此感到非常兴奋。我是一个非常理想主义、书呆子气的年轻人。研究和阅读关于宪法的内容——我爸爸是一位历史老师，他非常热情地谈论这份文件的天才之处，以及它演化并以某种方式超越和纠正其创始人缺陷的能力。就像，有一种想法，即存在一份由有缺陷的人创造的文件，它可能比创造它的人更好。
When you say that I'm reminded of this famous quote from Bill Clinton where he said-- and I think this is such a beautiful quote, too-- where he said, there's nothing that's wrong with America that what's right with America can't fix.
当你这么说时，我被比尔·克林顿那句名言提醒了——我认为那也是一句非常美丽的名言——他说，美国没有任何问题是美国正确的东西不能解决的。
Yes. I mean, Frederick Douglass has the similar quote which is that, like, yes, the Constitution was founded on the great evil compromise of slavery but that it also contained the means by which we could rectify that evil.
是的。我的意思是，弗雷德里克·道格拉斯也有类似的引言，就是，是的，宪法是建立在奴隶制这个伟大的邪恶妥协之上的，但它也包含了我们可以用来纠正那种邪恶的手段。
And so your play is partly about that hopeful feeling that you had about the Constitution when you were a kid.
所以你的剧部分是关于你小时候对宪法的那种希望感。
Yes.
是的。
But also how you came to see it once you became an adult, as a deeply flawed document. You talk in the play about how especially the Constitution and American law really did not address things that affect you and members of your family, especially the women in your family, for just a long time.
但也关于你成年后如何看待它，作为一份有严重缺陷的文件。你在戏中谈到，尤其是宪法和美国法律长期以来确实没有解决影响你和你家人成员的事情，尤其是你家里的女性。
Yes, yes.
是的，是的。
And when it did finally get around to addressing women, it was late, and it came to it kind of creakily.
而当它最终开始关注女性时，已经很晚了，而且它显得有点吱嘎作响。
Yes, very creakily.
是的，非常吱嘎作响。
And there's a large section of the play where you talk about how to get women to be covered by the Constitution, lawyers and the justices had to kind of jury rig women into having rights using, for example, the Ninth Amendment.
剧中有一个很大的章节谈到，为了让女性被宪法覆盖，律师和大法官不得不通过使用，例如，第九修正案，把女性强行塞进去拥有权利。
Yes.
是的。
Can I ask you to just explain what the Ninth Amendment does?
我可以请你解释一下第九修正案的作用吗？
Sure, sure. So the Ninth Amendment, which was my favorite as a kid, says, the enumeration in the Constitution of certain rights shall not be construed to deny or disparage other rights.
当然，当然。所以第九修正案，我小时候最喜欢的一条，说，宪法中对某些权利的列举，不得被解释为否认或贬低其他权利。
I just want to say for radio, anyone that's listening, that you're just reciting that from memory.
我只想为广播说一句，对于任何听众，你是在背诵它。
I'm just reciting from memory. Yes.
我只是在凭记忆背诵。是的。
OK.
好的。
Well, it's technically "shall not be construed to deny or disparage others retained by the people," meaning that just because a certain right is not explicitly given to you in the Constitution, it doesn't mean you don't have that right. This amendment allows for the fact that the founders could not have imagined the future that we're living in now.
嗯，技术上是“不得被解释为否认或贬低由人民保留的其他权利”，意思是仅仅因为某项权利没有明确列在宪法中，并不意味着你没有那项权利。这条修正案允许存在这样一种事实，即创始人无法想象我们现在生活的未来。
Well, it's like them admitting it. It's like, we can't think through every possible thing in this one document.
嗯，这就像他们承认这一点。就像，我们不能在这单一的文件中考虑到每一种可能的情况。
Right. I also like to think that in 300 years they knew that the world would look very different.
对。我也喜欢认为在300年后，他们知道世界看起来会非常不同。
And in the play, though, you say, to actually get this thing to apply to women, Justice William O. Douglas has to come up with a concept which is so strange and so almost poetic, this idea of the penumbra.
但在剧中，你说，为了真正让这东西适用于女性，威廉·O·道格拉斯大法官必须想出一个概念，它是如此陌生，以至于几乎是诗意的，这个半影的概念。
Right.
对。
What is a penumbra? Here I am standing in the light, and there you are sitting in the darkness. And this space between us, this space right here of partial illumination, this shadowy space right here, this is a penumbra.
什么是半影？我就站在这里的光亮中，而你坐在黑暗中。而在我们之间的这个空间，就在这里的这种部分照明空间，这个阴影空间，就是一个半影。
William O. Douglas loved this penumbra metaphor and said that you could therefore take this idea that somewhere in the shadows of the Constitution, in this kind of in between shadowy space, are our rights we have not yet named. You could use the Ninth Amendment to essentially, like, shine a little light into the dark corners and say, OK, over there.
威廉·O·道格拉斯喜欢这个半影隐喻，并说你可以因此采取这种观点，即在宪法的阴影中，在中间这种阴影空间里，藏着我们尚未命名的权利。你可以利用第九修正案，基本上就像，照亮黑暗角落，说，好的，在那边。
And then as you say in the show, the Ninth Amendment combines with the 14th Amendment in a kind of Wonder Twins, power activation moment--
正如你在节目中所说，第九修正案与第14修正案结合，在一种奇迹双胞胎激活权力的瞬间——
Yes.
是的。
--to decide Roe versus Wade.
——来裁定罗伊诉韦德案。
Yes.
是的。
But the Ninth Amendment is also the way that birth control gets legalized in the '60s. And let's hear-- we're going to hear an excerpt now from the play.
但第九修正案也是避孕在60年代合法化的方式。让我们听听——我们要播放一段剧中的摘录。
OK.
好的。
And this is where you talk about how that came about. And it begins with you explaining how you and a friend got birth control.
这是你谈论它是如何发生的。它开始于你解释你和一个朋友如何获得节育措施。
Yes.
是的。
The same year you were doing these contests, when you were 15 you went to Planned Parenthood.
同一年你在参加比赛，当你15岁时去了计划生育协会。
Neither of us were having sex yet, but just we wanted to be on birth control just in case. You know, just in case we were in a hot tub and sperms might happen to attack us.
我们两人都还没发生性行为，但只是我们想为了以防万一而进行节育。你知道，以防万一我们在热水浴缸里，精子可能会攻击我们。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
OK, I mean, you can laugh, but be careful. Or, you know, in case of a real attack. What I didn't realize at the time is that birth control had only been legal for all women in this country for about 15 years. I mean, I was 15. So I thought it had been legal since the dawn of time. But no, no.
好的，我的意思是，你可以笑，但要小心。或者，你知道，以防真正的袭击。我当时没意识到的是，节育在那之前在全国范围内对所有女性合法化才大约15年。我的意思是，我当时15岁。所以我以为它从时间之初就合法了。但没有，没有。
In 1965, this incredible woman, Estelle Griswold, got herself arrested for dispensing IUDs to poor women at her Connecticut Planned Parenthood. She faced a year in prison, took her case all the way to the Supreme Court, and this, this is actually when William O. Douglas first pulled out his big penumbra metaphor. This is when he said for the first time that one thing the Constitution surely guarantees is the right to privacy, and that this allows a woman to put in an IUD as long as she is married and as long as her husband says that it is OK.
1965年，这位了不起的女士，埃斯特尔·格里斯沃尔德，因在她的康涅狄格州计划生育协会向贫困妇女发放宫内节育器而被捕。她面临一年监禁，将案件一直告到了最高法院，而这，实际上是威廉·O·道格拉斯第一次拿出他的大半影隐喻。这是他第一次说宪法肯定保证的一件事就是隐私权，而这允许女性只要结婚并且丈夫同意，就可以放入宫内节育器。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
This is a very scary moment for William O. Douglas because nobody understands the Ninth Amendment-- nobody, except for me at 15. Justice Scalia said he didn't even remember studying it in law school. But they had to dig up this amendment that nobody understands, because there was just no other way to deal with the female body.
这对威廉·O·道格拉斯来说是一个非常可怕的时刻，因为没有人理解第九修正案——没有人，除了我15岁的时候。斯卡利亚大法官说他甚至不记得在法学院学习过它。但他们必须挖掘出这条没有人理解的修正案，因为除了它，根本没有别的方法来处理女性身体。
Because they all wanted to make birth control legal. They did. They wanted it because-- well, because I found out that William O. Douglas, who was my hero when I was 15, Justice William O. Douglas was 67, and he was having an affair with a 22-year-old college student.
因为他们都想让节育合法化。他们确实想。他们想要它是因为——嗯，因为我发现威廉·O·道格拉斯，我15岁时的英雄，威廉·O·道格拉斯大法官当时67岁，他和一个22岁的大学生有染。
[GASPING]
[喘气声]
So I'm thinking-- right? They want to find a way to get the birth control flowing. Actually, Arabella, can you play a snippet of the Supreme Court recording? This is the actual argument. So remember, it's 1965. There will not be a woman on this court until Sandra Day O'Connor arrives in 1981. Here are nine men deciding the fate of birth control.
所以我当时在想——对吧？他们想找到一种方法让节育普及。实际上，阿拉贝拉，你能播放一段最高法院录音的片段吗？这是实际的争论。记住，是1965年。在1981年桑德拉·戴·奥康纳到达之前，这个法院不会有女性。这是九名男子决定节育的命运。
All of these devices that are covered, that each of them has the potential dual function of acting in a contraceptive capacity and as a prevention of disease?
所有这些被覆盖的设备，它们每一个都具有作为避孕和预防疾病的双重功能？
It's probably only true with respect to some. But some get by under the term "feminine hygiene."
这可能只适用于其中一部分。但有些以“女性卫生”的名义混过去了。
And all this-- [CLEARING THROAT]-- uh-- [CLEARING THROAT]-- uh-- I just don't know about. But-- [CLEARING THROAT]-- uh-- [CLEARING THROAT]-- they are-- they are all sold in Connecticut drugstores on one theory or another.
而所有这些——[清嗓子]——呃——[清嗓子]——呃——我只是不知道关于这个。但——[清嗓子]——呃——[清嗓子]——它们——它们都在康涅狄格州的药店里以某种理论出售。
Is there anything on the record to-- [CLEARING THROAT]-- to indicate-- [CLEARING THROAT]-- the standard of birth rate in Connecticut vis-a-vis the states that don't have such laws?
记录上有什么——[清嗓子]——指示——[清嗓子]——康涅狄格州的出生率标准与没有这种法律的州相比吗？
It's, like, four hours of that.
差不多有四个小时都是那样。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
When Heidi Schreck was publicizing her show, she did this interview with Tony Kushner, the playwright and the Pulitzer prize winner, probably best known for Angels in America. And in this interview, they had this interesting exchange. Kushner says to her that he thought that her show was partly about this thing that he has been writing about and thinking about ever since he wrote that movie about Abraham Lincoln a few years ago that Stephen Spielberg directed.
当海蒂·舒瑞克为她的节目宣传时，她接受了托尼·库什纳的采访，他是剧作家、普利策奖得主，可能因《天使在美国》而最出名。在这次采访中，他们进行了有趣的交流。库什纳对她说，他认为她的演出部分是关于他自从几年前写了那部史蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格执导的亚伯拉罕·林肯电影后就一直在写和思考的事情。
Kushner said that in his view, a central question of democracy is that there needs to be some kind of mystical bond holding everybody together. Lincoln talked about the mystic chords of memory and very consciously tried to pull everybody together into allegiance for the Union. But Kushner said that if you actually interrogate what the thing is that is actually pulling us together, it's really just a stack of paper, right? It's just an act of faith that we have with each other. And he pointed out that how, of course, everybody knows right now this act of faith, this feeling that we are all in this together and we are one people who can work things out together, that is in such short supply.
库什纳说，在他看来，民主的一个核心问题是需要某种神秘的纽带将每个人联系在一起。林肯谈到了记忆的神秘和弦，并非常有意识地试图将每个人拉到一起忠诚于联邦。但库什纳说，如果你真正审视那件正在把我们拉在一起的东西，那真的只是一叠纸，对吧？这只是我们彼此之间的一种信念行为。他指出，当然，现在每个人都知道这种信念行为，这种感觉我们都在一起、是一个可以共同解决问题的民族的感觉，是多么稀缺。
And the very idea of teenagers giving speeches about that stack of papers, about the Constitution, and its importance and its values, Kushner said-- I'm quoting here-- "It feels like an ethos of a not very distant and yet somehow very distant past, where people believe in fairness, that the superstructure that we've all sworn allegiance to, the Constitution, is going to create opportunities and possibilities." That really hit me when I read it. And I asked Heidi Schreck in our interview if she agreed that the America where she gave those speeches when she was 15 seemed very far away.
而青少年发表演讲关于那叠纸、关于宪法及其重要性和价值的整个想法，库什纳说——我引用这里——“这感觉像是一种并不遥远却又显得非常遥远的过去的精神，那时人们相信公平，认为我们都宣誓效忠的超结构，即宪法，将创造机遇和可能性。”当我读到这一段时，我深受震撼。在采访中，我问海蒂·舒瑞克，她是否同意她15岁时发表演讲的那个美国看起来已经非常遥远了。
Yes.
是的。
How so?
怎么讲？
Well, so this was the '80s, between '86 and '89. First of all, I felt-- I mean, I was very liberal in high school. You know, I was feminist, liberal. Like, my speeches reflected those values, and I remember giving a speech about the Second Amendment, which I was arguing for gun control, because there had just been a shooting in California at a McDonald's. And I was arguing for strict gun control laws in front of a room of men who, you know, all owned guns and went hunting. And I won that contest.
嗯，那是80年代，在86年到89年之间。首先，我觉得——我的意思是，我在高中时非常自由派。你知道，我是女性主义者、自由主义者。就像，我的演讲反映了那些价值观，我记得我做过关于第二修正案的演讲，我是在争论枪支管制，因为当时在加州的一家麦当劳发生了一起枪击案。我是在一群男人面前争论严格的枪支管制法律，你知道，他们都拥有枪支并去狩猎。而且我赢得了那场比赛。
And I always felt a sense that these men I was, you know, giving the speeches for supported my right to have a different view than they did, supported my right as an American to express myself, believed it was important in a democracy that we have these conversations together. So that felt different to me. I will also say, this was, like, the very beginning of Rush Limbaugh, you know, and then Fox News.
而且我一直感觉到这些我为他们做演讲的男人，你知道，支持我有与他们不同的观点的权利，支持我作为美国人表达自己的权利，相信在民主国家中我们共同进行这些对话很重要。所以那对我来说感觉不同。我还要说，这简直就是拉什·林博开始的时候，你知道，然后是福克斯新闻。
And those men who gave you award money after you argued against the--
而那些在你反对——之后给你奖金的男人们——
Yeah, yeah.
是的，是的。
--the Second Amendment, you think that that would be-- it might be harder today.
——第二修正案，你认为那会是——今天可能更困难。
I think so. Although I will say, I looked on YouTube at other American Legion speeches. And they still seem to be-- like, the winners often seem to be quite liberal. So at least maybe in the space of the American Legion, there's still room for this kind of dialogue.
我想是吧。虽然我不得不说，我在YouTube上看了其他美国军团的演讲。而且他们看起来仍然是——就像，获胜者似乎经常是相当自由派的。所以至少在美国军团的空间里，似乎还有这种对话的余地。
I hope.
我希望如此。
I hope too.
我也希望如此。
Heidi Schreck. If you're visiting New York City, her show What the Constitution Means to Me, is running through July on Broadway. A little Constitutional footnote here-- after we recorded that interview, I learned that the 14th and Ninth Amendments did not really combine Wonder Twins style to decide Roe versus Wade. Technically, the 14th decided Roe, with the Ninth justifying an important precedent that's cited in the case.
海蒂·舒瑞克。如果你在访问纽约市，她的节目《宪法对我意味着什么》正在百老汇上演，一直持续到7月。这里有一个小小的宪法脚注——在我们录完那次采访后，我了解到第14和第九修正案并没有真正结合成奇迹双胞胎风格来裁定罗伊诉韦德案。技术上是第14修正案裁定了罗伊案，而第九修正案证明了一个案例中引用的重要先例的正当性。
[MUSIC - "THIS LAND IS YOUR LAND" BY SHARON JONES AND THE DAP-KINGS]
[音乐——莎朗·琼斯和Dap-Kings演唱的《这片土地是你的土地》]
Well, our program was produced today by Lina Misitzis and Ben Calhoun. The people who put our show together includes Aviva DeKornfeld, Jarrett Floyd, Damien Graef, Miki Meek, Stowe Nelson, Zoe Oliver-Grey, Nadia Reiman, Robyn Semien, Louis Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Nancy Updike, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor is David Kestenbaum. Special thanks to David Jacob Weisberg, Nicole Capatasto, Matt Ross, Sarah Sgro, Lawrence Tribe, Sara Holdren and New York Magazine, Krys Jensen and everyone at the South Mountain YMCA where we set up the tattle-phone, Michael Radolinksy and the folks at Fete-phone, who made the phone that we used to record the kids' tattles.
好了，我们的节目今天由莉娜·米西齐斯和本·卡尔霍恩制作。负责把我们节目整合在一起的人包括阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德、贾里特·弗洛伊德、达米安·格拉夫、三木·米克、斯托·纳尔逊、佐伊·奥利弗-格雷、纳迪亚·雷曼、罗宾·塞米恩、路易斯·沙利文、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼、南希·厄普代克、朱莉·惠特克和黛安·吴。我们的总编辑是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。特别感谢大卫·雅各布·韦斯伯格、妮可·卡帕塔斯托、马特·罗斯、莎拉·斯格罗、劳伦斯·特里布、莎拉·霍尔德伦和《纽约杂志》，克里斯·詹森以及我们设置告密电话所在的南山基督教青年会的每一个人，迈克尔·拉多林斯基和Fete-phone的伙计们，他们制造了我们用来记录孩子们告密的电话。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our archive of over 600 shows, or download the archive using the This American Life app. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he said this thing the other day that is a perfect illustration why you should not combine micro-dosing with babysitting.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以收听我们超过600场节目的存档，或者使用《美国生活》应用程序下载存档。《美国生活》由PRX公共广播交换中心发送给公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，他前几天说的这件事是为什么你不应该把微剂量与保姆工作结合起来的完美例证。
Uh, our baby turned into a ducky, and I don't know how it turn into a ducky and turn back to a baby.
呃，我们的宝宝变成了一只小鸭子，我不知道它是怎么变成小鸭子的，又变回了宝宝。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。